you like doing a cover of song or is it
fun because All Along the Watchtower you
do that all the time yeah we haven't we
haven't done it for a little while but
that's um but that's yeah that that was
I actually learned that Psalm because I
was um a long long time ago I I did it
as a
when I was living in Amsterdam and
selling little bracelets I bought in in
Africa and I was you know things were
going well I was trying to smoke weed
and and eat some sandwiches and go to
the um there was a little uh free lunch
served by the I think The Hare krishnas
and I'd go and eat their Brown slop
right and
um and then I'd play but the convenience
with with all on the Watchtower is when
it was a little bit chilly I could just
play the song I could just never stop
playing it yeah it's a it's a little
monotonous isn't it and that's what I
just would play it this way and that way
just go around and just not stop do you
like it because of the Hendrix version
or did you like it because it was a Bob
Dylan song yes yes both yeah and you got
turned on to it yeah and then there's
and then I was also like well you can
play this sort of any way and and so I
just people accept it yeah yeah and
they're not really listening they're
just walking past and if they feel sorry
for you because you're wearing you know
the knees are ripped open in your pants
and then throw some money in there yeah
there was a point in your career you
used to busk that's what they call it
right yeah busting yeah I did it I did
it you would go out on the street and
perform yeah and then get shouted at by
the buskers that had set up they'll be
like this is my place could you make a
decent living doing that I did okay I
mean I wasn't you know I wasn't buying
airline flights anywhere but there are
people who can but I was not prepared
for the they're they're professional
buskers who kill I mean they make a
killing and you would just go out on the
street and open up your suitcase open up
your guitar case and people would throw
money in it would people ever steal the
money out of this out of the guitar case
no the Dutch are very nice people right
and when you do that is do you you would
first walk out on the sidewalk because I
can't imagine this is there just this
pounding nervousness like I'm opening up
a guitar case and I'm just going to
start playing Guitar see there was a
pounding nervousness when I was 19. so
that was it was a debilitating fear and
then I just stopped doing it and no one
would pay any attention that maybe one
person might stop I wasn't it was not my
my greatest moment but were there
certain songs that would bring in tons
of money yes all on the watchtowers is
all it was right like I said it was just
that song I mean I'm not kidding how
long would you do all along do it for an
hour seriously until someone told me to
stop and shut up I did have one really
humiliating experience which I'm sure
people that listen to your show would
would afford me the same experience if
they had the opportunity a guy came up
and just put his hand on the strings and
said
stop he said please shh and then walked
away with his pretty girl Dutch
girlfriends and they all ha ha and I was
just like crushed like I was just in
other words you're making noise here
you're annoying everyone get the [__]
out yeah and I'm making I'm gonna make
you into a joke for my smoking hot girl
Dutch girlfriends what are you doing a
guy does that I just feel stunned do you
go home or do you go back to the thing
wait until he was way out of sight and
then try to start feeling like even more
[__] [__] yeah but that's but at
the same time I could also see you know
there's moments when you see someone
that's a little vulnerable and then
you're like I got a funny trick I mean
it I guess people that's what you know
but isn't it amazing that you were
strong enough not to quit the business
like some people do some people are like
wow I'm getting a really that was the
worst well yeah they do and they give up
I think it'd be harder to for in a way
for me like I when I when when people go
and sing in this in the subway man you
got to know you're good you got to know
you're good you got to know self-defense
yeah you gotta know a lot yeah this is
unbelievable
foreign